selbstfahrende autos sind hier sie
dürfen zwar auf den meisten straßen noch
nicht fahren und es gibt noch viele
hürden die wir überwinden müssen aber in
absehbarer zeit werden selbst fahren
autos unser aller leben verändern
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
what's on so wie bei vielen anderen
erfindungen die hier schon vorgestellt
habe machen leute wenn es um die zukunft
geht oft denselben fehler
sie stellen sich eine welt wie heute vor
mit dem einzigen unterschied dass es
diese eine erfindung mehr gibt im fall
von selbstfahrenden autos gehen die
leute davon aus dass sie halt in der
zukunft nicht mehr das lenkrad selber
festhalten müssen
wenn man so weiter denkt dann ist es ja
auch klar dass viele leute diese neuen
selbstfahrenden autos als luxus feature
abtun das vielleicht in zehn bis 20
prozent aller autos verbaut wird
aber man muss eben auch immer mit
bedenken dass sich die welt weiter
entwickelt auch der computer wurde
anfangs massiv unterschätzt aber man
kann es den leuten auch kaum übelnehmen
oder ein riesiges gerät das unmengen
kostet einen ganzen raum einnimmt und
nur wenige mathematische rechnungen für
einen erledigt das ist eine erfindung
die für den durchschnittlichen haushalt
einfach komplett uninteressant ist aber
entwicklungen wie das internet laptop
smartphone betriebssysteme
das sind dinge die den computer
unglaublich interessant gemacht haben
und somit wurden möglichkeiten
erschaffen die man vorher gar nicht
hätte vorhersehen können wer konnte
schon ahnen dass man mit dem computer in
der zukunft zeitungen lesen filme gucken
mit freunden reden bewerbungen schreiben
oder spiele spielen kann
und genauso verhält es sich mit den
selbstfahrenden autos zugegeben dass
selbst fahren auto ist kein medium
welches ein neues zeitalter der
kommunikation auslösen kann
aber es wird aufgabenfelder geben die
wir uns heute noch gar nicht vorstellen
können von denen wir uns dann in 20
jahren fragen werden die wir bis jetzt
ohne die ausgekommen sind so wie wir uns
heute fragen wie wir ohne netflix oder
spotify ohne facebook oder generell ohne
computer am arbeitsplatz jemals
ausgekommen sind selbst fahrende autos
können sich von den heutigen autos so
sehr unterscheiden wie das iphone von
einem computer aus dem letzten
jahrtausend
zuerst werden die selbstfahrende autos
in bereichen durchsetzen in denen
dadurch viele arbeitskräfte eingespart
werden können so wird zum beispiel jetzt
schon damit experimentiert lkw caravan
von bis zu drei lkw hintereinander
fahren zu lassen wobei aber nur ein
fahrer im vordersten lkw
die anderen beiden vehikel sind drahtlos
miteinander verbunden und bremsen
beschleunigen und lenken genauso wie es
der erste lkw tut besonders auf langen
geraden autobahnstrecken kann man so
sehr viele arbeitskräfte und durch den
windschatten auch viel treibstoff sparen
außerdem glaube ich dass viele von uns
in zukunft kein auto mehr selber
besitzen werden die allermeisten
menschen fahren mit ihrem 4 oder 5
sitzer 10 bis 20 minuten zur arbeit und
wieder zurück 90 prozent der zeit bleibt
das auto stehen und wenn es fährt werden
tonnenweise stahl befördert die man
normalerweise gar nicht braucht aber
wenn autos in der zukunft ohne fahrer
auskommen werden dann wird es total
verschwenderisch sein
ein auto zu besitzen das die ganzen
zeiten rumsteht stattdessen denke ich
dass man sich autos und zukunft wie ein
taxi ruft und zwar je nach bedarf die
entsprechende größe fünf leute mit
gepäck mini werden alleine zur arbeit
elektrische zweisitzer und wenn man
nicht mal über die autobahn muss dann
kriegt man vielleicht dann auch so dass
zwar nicht schneller als 50 km/h fahren
kann dafür aber besonders energiesparend
ist
die größte änderung werden aber autos
die dafür ausgelegt sind da keine
menschen zu befördern
wieso sollte ein pizzalieferant sich
selber und eine tonne stahl bewegen wenn
man doch nur eine 500 gramm pizza
liefern soll
wie werden die hl wagen aussehen die
ihre pakete von alleine ausliefern quasi
ohne irgendwelche hilfe wird es
supermärkte gegen die nur noch im
internet sind quasi wie ein amazon
lieferdienste selbst fahren autos werden
kein luxus feature weil es die software
ist die das auto intelligent macht und
die kann man millionenfach kopieren
aufspielen und updaten sobald sie
marktreif ist
die sensoren mit denen das auto dann
später sehen und hören kann
die werden von jahr zu jahr günstiger
und vielleicht lohnt es sich irgendwann
alleine wegen des geringeren
unfallrisikos auf einen selbst fahrendes
auto umzusteigen denn für die
versicherung gibt es keinen besseren
kunden als denen wir einen kleinen
beitrag zahlt dafür aber niemals in
einen unfall kommt ich mache jetzt mal
die ganz mutige vorhersage dass es
irgendwann sogar verboten sein wird
selber zu fahren
einfach weil es autos gibt die viel
sicherer sind als menschen menschliche
fehler sind dann das einzige große
risiko
so etwas wurde auch schon im film i
robot angedeutet und in der sekunde in
der kein mensch mehr selber fährt können
noch viel viel bessere dinge geschehen
überlegt euch mal wie präzise ein selbst
fahrendes auto planen kann wenn es
gleichzeitig auch die routen und
ähnlichkeiten der anderen autos kämen
man bräuchte für autos sogar eigentlich
gar keine ampeln mehr da jedes auto
genau weiß wann es an eine kreuzung
kommt und sich bei einer möglichen
kollision mit dem anderen auto dann
minuten vorher absprechen kann dann
fährt das eine minimal schneller und das
andere minimal langsamer und an der
kreuzung fahren beide aneinander vorbei
ohne sich zu berühren
klar dauert es noch eine ganze weile bis
wir überhaupt dahin kommen zum beispiel
müssen uns dringend mal mit der frage
beschäftigen wer für einen eventuellen
unfall verantwortlich ist der fahrer der
eigentlich gar nicht aktiv am geschehen
beteiligt war
der autohersteller oder der
software-entwickler beide von den
letzteren waren eigentlich gar nicht am
unfallort
ich bin sehr gespannt wann das erste
richtige selbst fahrende auto auf
unseren straßen fahren wird was ist eure
meinung zu dem thema bin ich auch sehr
gespannt auf eure meinung schreibt mir
unten auf jeden fall in die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet
hier sind auch meine beiden letzten
videos von what's on und zwar einmal wie
verändern 3d drucker unser leben und
bionische prothesen sind wir auf dem weg
zum super menschen ansonsten vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal